who introduced me to the effects of combat on the psyche.
While my grandfather was serving as a Marine in the Korean War,
a bullet pierced his neck and rendered him unable to cry out.
He watched as a corpsman passed him over,
declaring him a goner,
and then leaving him to die.
Years later, after his physical wounds had healed
and he'd returned home,
he rarely spoke of his experiences in waking life.
But at night I would hear him shouting obscenities
from his room down the hall.
And during the day I would announce myself as I entered the room,
careful not to startle or agitate him.
He lived out the remainder of his days
isolated and tight-lipped,
never finding a way to express himself,
and I didn't yet have the tools to guide him.
I wouldn't have a name for my grandfather's condition
until I was in my 20s.
Seeking a graduate degree in art therapy,
I naturally gravitated towards the study of trauma.
And while sitting in class learning about post-traumatic stress disorder,
or PTSD for short,
my mission to help service members who suffered like my grandfather
began to take form.
We've had various names for post-traumatic stress
throughout the history of war:
homesickness,
soldier's heart,
shell shock,
thousand-yard stare, for instance.
And while I was pursuing my degree, a new war was raging,
and thanks to modern body armor and military vehicles,
service members were surviving blast injuries they wouldn't have before.
But the invisible wounds were reaching new levels,
and this pushed military doctors and researchers
to try and truly understand the effects that traumatic brain injury, or TBI,
and PTSD have on the brain.
Due to advances in technology and neuroimaging,
we now know there's an actual shutdown in the Broca's,
or the speech-language area of the brain, after an individual experiences trauma.
This physiological change,
or speechless terror as it's often called,
coupled with mental health stigma,
the fear of being judged
or misunderstood,
possibly even removed from their current duties,
has led to the invisible struggles of our servicemen and women.
Generation after generation of veterans
have chosen not to talk about their experiences,
and suffer in solitude.
I had my work cut out for me when I got my first job
as an art therapist at the nation's largest military medical center,
Walter Reed.
After working for a few years on a locked-in patient psychiatric unit,
I eventually transferred to the National Intrepid Center of Excellence, NICoE,
which leads TBI care for active duty service members.
Now, I believed in art therapy,
but I was going to have to convince service members,
big, tough, strong, manly military men,
and some women too,
to give art-making as a psychotherapeutic intervention a try.
The results have been nothing short of spectacular.
Vivid, symbolic artwork
is being created by our servicemen and women,
and every work of art tells a story.
We've observed that the process of art therapy bypasses
the speech-language issue with the brain.
Art-making accesses the same sensory areas of the brain that encode trauma.
Service members can use the art-making to work through their experiences
in a nonthreatening way.
They can then apply words to their physical creations,
reintegrating the left and the right hemispheres of the brain.
Now, we've seen this can work with all forms of art --
drawing, painting, collage --
but what seems to have the most impact
is mask-making.
Finally, these invisible wounds don't just have a name,
they have a face.
And when service members create these masks,
it allows them to come to grips, literally, with their trauma.
And it's amazing how often that enables them
to break through the trauma and start to heal.
Remember BFIB?
That was a real experience for one of my patients,
and when he created his mask,
he was able to let go of that haunting image.
Initially, it was a daunting process for the service member,
but eventually he began to think of BFIB as the mask,
not his internal wound,
and he would go to leave each session,
he would hand me the mask, and say, "Melissa, take care of him."
Eventually, we placed BFIB in a box to further contain him,
and when the service member went to leave the NICoE,
he chose to leave BFIB behind.
A year later, he had only seen BFIB twice,
and both times BFIB was smiling
and the service member didn't feel anxious.
Now, whenever that service member is haunted by some traumatic memory,
he continues to paint.
Every time he paints these disturbing images,
he sees them less or not at all.
Philosophers have told us for thousands of years
that the power to create
is very closely linked to the power to destroy.
Now science is showing us that the part of the brain
that registers a traumatic wound
can be the part of the brain where healing happens too.
And art therapy is showing us how to make that connection.
We asked one of our service members
to describe how mask-making impacted his treatment,
and this is what he had to say.
(Video) Service Member: You sort of just zone out into the mask.
You zone out into the drawing,
and for me, it just released the block,
so I was able to do it.
And then when I looked at it after two days, I was like,
"Holy crap, here's the picture, here's the key, here's the puzzle,"
and then from there it just soared.
I mean, from there my treatment just when out of sight,
because they were like, Kurt, explain this, explain this.
And for the first time in 23 years,
I could actually talk about stuff openly to, like, anybody.
I could talk to you about it right now if I wanted to,
because it unlocked it.
It's just amazing.
And it allowed me to put 23 years of PTSD
and TBI stuff together in one place
that has never happened before.
Sorry.
Melissa Walker: Over the past five years,
we've had over 1,000 masks made.
It's pretty amazing, isn't it?
Thank you.
(Applause)
I wish I could have shared this process with my grandfather,
but I know that he would be thrilled
that we are finding ways
to help today's and tomorrow's service members heal,
and finding the resources within them
that they can call upon
to heal themselves.
Thank you.
(Applause)